hello I'm going to show some interesting
new ways you can create web interfaces
with version 11 in version 10 we
introduced the Wolfram cloud a way to
develop and deploy programs with the
Wolfram language it's true you can write
every part of a web interface yourself
from the ground up and we've made some
of that easier in version 11 with things
like generate HTTP response and URL
dispatcher but in version 11 we've also
added more high-level declarative ways
to create interfaces form page he is
similar to form function but instead of
just showing the results keeps the form
so you can keep interacting with it
let's try it so here we see the form and
let's try three sides so now we see both
the result in the form with form
function you just get this triangle here
with form page we have the form itself
so we can view the result at the same
time as we're entering more input
without having to hit the browser back
button so you can appreciate certain
types of forms will lend themselves to
this interface and certain to form
function form functions good for
something like an online poll you want
to accept inputs show a result and move
on forum page is good for letting a user
kind of explore what changes in response
to different inputs now along with this
is the auto submitting wrapper this is
useful if you want the form to update
whenever a field has changed so this is
similar to the previous form but we've
got this Auto submitting wrapper around
the interpreter specification in this
case we've made it a slider that's
restricted to a certain range of number
of sides let's see how this works
here we've got our slider pick a number
of sides and we can change it now you
may be saying to yourself big deal form
that draws a polygon but that that's not
really the point is it the point is how
little effort it took to produce this
interface with all the HTML CSS and
JavaScript it gets generated for you the
point is to take your ideas and get them
onto the web into the hands of your
users just as quickly let's look at
something a bit different this is a
simple idea and something you definitely
could do yourself but it can be handy
that it's already done for you this
gallery view symbol creates a browsable
gallery of images first note that this
is a simple cloud deploy of a gallery
view expression and there's a list of
expressions here you can just have a
list like this or you can have a title
and labels for everything in an
association so let's look at the version
that already has the the title and
labels so there's a couple of things
that are done automatically for you one
is it handles a layout it's items onto a
row depending on the page size and two
handles pagination in this case there's
so many polyhedra that we've got it
looks like ten pages and it's it's
generated this pagination interface
itself and its handling all that that's
pretty nice set of features to be
handled automatically
next thing we'll look at is ask function
I think this is an incredibly neat idea
the way you use this is you write code
like you would perform page or form
function but you sprinkle the code with
a scrappers these go off to the user and
collect information it works really well
with complicated problems where
sometimes you need information only in
certain cases and based on previous
answers and what better place to go for
an example of something complicated than
the US tax system so this example plays
accountant and attempts to tell you your
marginal tax rate based on asking
questions like your filing status
independence and so on so you can see in
the code it starts by asking about
filing status and gives up gives a form
function like input specification and it
continues with the calculation and let's
see here is a yes or no question do you
have any dependents and only if it gives
a yes answer and it's asking how many so
let's try this
okay so we're going to select our status
give an income level say yes we have
dependents and they come Cheaper by the
Dozen so we're going to say 12 and it
computes our answer that is a pretty
neat little web tool to come from this
small an amount of code let's look at
one last thing so sometimes you don't
know how many fields you're going to
need for a form the repeating element
wrapper lets you have more than one of
the same sort of field in this example
we want to collect multiple addresses so
we can create a map of travel directions
so in this case we specify we want
between two and five street addresses
this is an interpreter type using this
repeating element wrapper and what comes
out when we generate the form is it
automatically shows the the minimum of
two addresses then it has these plus and
minus buttons that let the user add more
or subtract one from its list of
addresses and finally when you submit
the form you see the the map of the trip
again all of this code you need to
handle these various numbers of inputs
is handled for you and all of these
tools and more are available in version
11 and let you get your applications
online hosted in the Wolfram cloud with
relatively very little code thank you